Four people earn $180
for working at an
after-school program.
If they divide this money up
equally, how much will each
person receive?
So we want to divide $180 into
four equal groups so that each
of the four people can
have the same amount.
So we want to divide 180 by 4.
We want to take 180
divided by 4.
Now, most of us don't know this
off the top of our heads,
so we need to solve for it.
We need to do a little
bit of division.
So another way of writing this
exact same expression is to
write 4 divided into 180.
And when you write it like this,
it's easier to do it if
either of them actually has
more than one digit,
especially if the number we're
dividing into has more than
one or two or three
or four digits.
So let's do it.
So the first thing you say is,
well, does 4 go into 1?
Well, no, 4 does
not go into 1.
It's larger than 1.
So you could put a 0 up here,
but instead of doing that,
let's just move on to the right
and say, well, OK, it
doesn't go into 1.
Does 4 go into 18?
Well, 4 times 4 is 16,
so that goes into 18
at least four times.
4 times 5-- let me
write this down.
4 times 4 is equal to 16,
so that goes into 18.
4 times 5 is equal to 20, so
that does not go into 18, so
this is going to go into
18 four times.
4 times 4 is 16, and
now we subtract.
We essentially find the
remainder here.
18 minus 6 is 2.
Now we want to bring down this
0, because we really said 4
goes into 180 40 times, because
it's in the tens place.
40 times 4 is 160.
180 minus 160 is 20.
That's why we bring
down the 0.
But if you just think about
the process, you say, OK,
what's the smallest-- if I just
go with the 1, 4 doesn't
go into it, so let me move on.
Let me look at the
1 and the 8, 18.
4 goes into that four times.
4 times 4 is 16.
Subtract from 18, you get
a 2, bring down the 0.
Now 4 goes into 20
how many times?
Well, we just wrote
it over here.
4 times 5 is equal to 20.
So 4 goes into 20 five times.
5 times 4 is 20.
You subtract, and you have
no remainder left over.
So 180 divided by 4
is equal to 45.
So if these four people were
to split the money equally,
they'll each get $45.